c'est pour nous africains de porter à la
tête de nos états des gens qui sont
animés par la recherche de l'intérêt de
leur population
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite fait les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce lundi 19 octobre 2009
l'hommage national hassan elle pâtit
aura lieu mercredi dans la cour de la
sorbonne en attendant lé enquête se
poursuit après l'assassinât de cet
enseignant vendredi à conflans sainte
honorine
quinze personnes sont en garde à vue
dont quatre collégiens elle l'exécutif
promet des réponses à court et moyen
terme
le ministre de l'intérieur hausse le ton
et prévoit de mener une vingtaine de
contrôles quotidiens en visant des
structures aux personnes soupçonnées de
liens avec la mouvance islamiste
le coronavirus pas d'amélioration trop
tôt encore pour observer les effets du
couvre feu entré en vigueur le week-end
dernier
ailleurs en europe la situation est tout
aussi inquiétante le pays de galles des
crêtes de semaine de confinement est les
cafés et restaurants ferment leurs
portes pour un mois en belgique
angela merkel demande de restreindre les
relations sociales en allemagne le bric
site chaque camp avance ses pions un
négociée n'a pas de sens sans changement
de position de l'union européenne dit
londres tout en affirmant être ouvert à
la négociation
lui se dit elle disponible pour négocier
par la voix de michel barnier le royaume
uni et l'union européenne ont discuté
aujourd'hui du format de négociations
sur leurs relations futures
mais les points d'achoppement subsistent
[Musique]
et on débute avec les suites de
l'attentât de conflans sainte honorine
vendredi au lendemain du conseil de
défense emmanuel macron la firme la peur
va changer de camp
réaction aussi de gérald darmanin le
ministre de l'intérieur a annoncé que
des opérations de police ont eu lieu ce
matin des dizaines d'islamistes et de
mouvances sont concernés mais les
autorités prévoient de mener une
vingtaine de contrôles quotidiens visant
des structures ou personnes soupçonnées
de liens avec la mouvance islamiste
selon l'entourage du ministre de
l'intérieur à l'elysée confirme aussi
que la vigilance sur internet sera
renforcée nous ne sommes plus dans l'âge
où la surcharge ou l'émotion mais bien
dans un travail de fond depuis vendredi
la plateforme de signalements pharos à
identifier 80 messages qui soutiennent
l'action de l'agresseur ils donneront
lieu dès lundi à des procédures
diligentées par la police ou la
gendarmerie
et selon un document confidentiel un
service de renseignement auraient eu
connaissance du risque
les détails avec kirikou titoff après le
choc viennent maintenant les
interrogations les services de
renseignement était-il au courant d'une
situation pour le moins tendues au
collège bois d'aulne de conflans
plusieurs jours avant le drame
on sait désormais que oui il l'était
selon une note du renseignement
territoriale qrt france a pu consulter
concernant les tensions au collège bois
d'aulne rédigé avant l'assassinât de
l'enseignant
les agents avaient jugé la situation
apaisée au 12 octobre déjà la
communication entre la direction de
l'établissement et les familles a
visiblement permis d'apaiser les
tensions au sein du collège
aucune tension majeure n'est palpable
tant du côté de la communauté éducative
que des fédérations de parents d'élèves
qui tout en reconnaissant une certaine
maladresse du professeur bien apprécié
par sa hiérarchie ne désavoue pas pour
autant le renseignement at il alors
sous-estimer la situation car bien que
l' enquête confirme aujourd'hui qu'il
n'existe aucun lien direct entre
l'enseignant samuel patty est le
terroriste abdullah en europe dont la
personnalité trouble continue d'être
étudiées par les enquêteurs certains
éléments semblent confirmer la thèse
selon laquelle le jeune homme aurait été
poussé dans son geste par le
comportement de certains protagonistes
notamment un parent d'élève et un
prédicateur islamiste
cette affaire aurait en effet pu s'en
tenir à la sphère privée des parents
d'élèves mécontents du comportement d'un
enseignant l'intervention du rectorat
pour régler le différend est un
apaisement à terme détention sauf que
cette affaire a pesé sur les réseaux
sociaux après plusieurs publications
posté par à père de famille qui montrant
son indignation en appelle clairement à
une action forte envers samuel pâti de
ceux qui ne sont pas d'accord avec fait
avec ce comportement au tout ce qu'ils
ont rencontré des difficultés ou leurs
enfants ils ont été renvoyés parce que
ma fille comme elle a refusé de sortir
de la classe le propre et l'a renvoyé de
la classe on l'aimé tant a un autre
motif
si vous voulez qu'on soit en forme et
ont conduit pop
je sais pas leurs enfants envoyez moi un
message
après plusieurs vidéos qui ont été
relayés des centaines de fois sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est au tour de
abdelhakim servat ou prédicateurs fiché
pour radicalisation de donner son avis
sur le sujet on a expliqué la gravité de
la chose mais ça n'avait pas l'air de
choquer autrement je veux dire la
principale ni la 70e apparemment il
était au courant et que ça se faisait
depuis cinq six ans ça fait cinq six ans
que des enfants de 12 13 ans d'aider des
musulmans sans choquer sont agressés
sans humilier devant leurs camarades
parce que c'est ce qu'ils nous ont dit
ceux avec qui on a parlé mais dans
l'après midi
l'inspection académique a contacté le
parent d'élève et il y avait exprimé je
veux dire aussi son étonnement de savoir
que ça s'est passé comme ça dans le
cours de ce voyou et que qu'ils allaient
sévir et de fil en aiguille les propos
prennent de l'ampleur les coordonnées de
l'enseignant sont révélés c'est alors
qu'abdou la hammer of 18 ans habitant à
evreux à 80km de conflans sainte
honorine prend connaissance de la sphère
l' enquête révélera que son compte
twitter était truffé de propos et
d'imagés extrêmement violente et que le
jeune homme était particulièrement porté
sur le terrorisme bien que non encore
fichés il avait déjà été repéré par de
nombreux internautes pour ses propos
haineux en août dernier comment un
différend entre un professeur et
quelques parents d'élèves at il pu se
terminer
et de manière aussi dramatique il semble
aujourd'hui évident que les réseaux
sociaux ont un rôle primordial dans
cette affaire le drame aurait-il pu
néanmoins être évité si le renseignement
avaient anticipé la situation
l'enquète pourrait montrer de nouveaux
éléments dans les jours à venir
en tout cas plus l'enquêté avance plus
le déroulé des faits fait froid dans le
dos quinze personnes sont en garde à vue
dont quatre collégiens il y avait eu
contact entre le tueur et des parents
d'élèves qui dénonçaient les caricatures
on appris également que le terroriste à
distribuer de l'argent aux collégiens en
échange de renseignements sur le
professeur assassinés alors dans
certaines zones l'école est elle
réellement gangréné par l'islamisme
radical place à notre décryptage avec
nos invités et pour en parler nous
sommes avec alexis poulard
éditorialistes bonsoir à vos côtés à
chaque milliard mer les républicains de
maisons laffitte c'est dans les yvelines
bonsoir alors avant de vous entendre
jacky milliard un témoignage celui de
rodrigo arenas c'est le vice président
de la fcpe
c'est la première association de parents
d'élèves il a reçu un signalement
vendredi dernier faisant état d'un père
extrêmement énervé après la publication
en classe d'une caricature de mahomet
regardez on en parle ensuite et que nous
avons signé les cela aux maires homero
pourquoi parce que nous avons estimé que
ce qui était diffusée sur les réseaux
sociaux étaient suffisamment probants
pour nous craindre un trouble à l'ordre
public et dans notre pays ceux qui sont
en charge de l'ordre public dans une
commune ça s'appelle le maire qui
ensuite évidemment travail avec les
services de police pour éviter les
débordements quel qu'il soit c'est pour
cela que j'ai fait prévenir le maire qui
m'a fait appeler dans la journée pour me
dire que toutes les dispositions ont été
prises sur la ville de conflans sainte
honorine
suite à ça ces messages qui circulait
sur les réseaux sociaux et que
l'éducation nationale parfaitement au
fait de l'es22 cette situation mettez
tout à disposition toutes les procédures
normales
en tout cas pas les procédures qui
existent pour ce type de cas ouais il a
donc prévenu le maire les maires en
première ligne jacques milliard vous
êtes en charge de l'ordre public alors
l'islamisme aux enfants dans les
collèges dans les lycées
est ce que c'est une vraie
est problématique aujourd'hui à laquelle
vous êtes confrontés côté à
maisons-laffitte jusqu'à présent en
dehors d'un cas d'un animateur sportif
qui avait refusé de serrer la main aux
femmes sous prétexte que c'était une
femme
nous n'avons heureusement pas eu de cas
mais je ne suis pas du tout étonné sur
ce qui se passe dans certaines villes
des yvelines
et vous savez il s'agit pas de parler
les écoles en réalité les écoles c'est
le reflet de ce que sont les quartiers
ne jamais oublier que les écoles
accueillent toute la population des
quartiers là où elles sont implantées
selon la carte scolaire
donc nous savons pertinemment qu'il y à
de profonds radicalisation de certains
quartiers et on les retrouve bien sûr à
l'école alors comment agir et c'est là
où aujourd'hui on a constaté qu'il y
avait eu un retard à l'allumage
depuis des années de l'instruction
publique de l'éducation nationale et que
dans un premier temps s'était pas de
vagues
on calme les choses on essaie d'arrondir
les angles est arrêté on a rendu rien du
tout face à quelque chose qui est un
franc sillage de la situation
internationale et de la cri de l'islam
au niveau international car ouvriers
bien que dans ce cas pas tant comme dans
le cas précédent où c'était un
pakistanais là c'est un tchétchène
ces gens là ont importé leur haine et
leur conviction religieuse
en arrivant en france et c'est là où on
a été d'une naïveté complète car il faut
contrôler et bien évidemment les gens
qui rentrent chez nous et eux aussi
pouvoir expulser très rapidement les
gens qui se conduisent contrairement à
l'ordre public
non pas l'orgue avec je dirais un casque
de cerexhe c'est à dire c'est
l'ordonnancement juridique de notre
société qui est mise à mal et on veut
imposer la charia c'est à dire la loi
divine de l'interprétation du coran pas
les intégristes voilà donc il ya pour
moi malheureusement connaissant la
dérive de l'islam depuis une trentaine
d'années ayant fait ça
2 rapport à l'assemblée nationale je
suis désolé c'est odieux de ce que je
vais dire mais je ne suis pas
malheureusement pas surpris et je peux
vous dire que un ami professeur dans une
autre ville des yvelines vient de
m'appeler pour me dire attention je suis
aussi très fébrile parce que nous avons
des menaces alexis poulain on entendait
aller à l'instant jacques milliards nous
dire que c'était la politique du pas de
vagues dans les écoles dans l'éducation
nationale ce drame qu'est ce qu'il
révèle pour vous sur la liberté
pédagogique des professeurs aujourd'hui
elle n'a pas été assez défendue non elle
n'a pas été assez défendu c'est vrai
qu'il faut rappeler que les professeurs
ont cette liberté pédagogique qui leur
permettent d'adapter le programme de le
suivre bien entendu mais de pouvoir
choisir comment aborder les thématiques
du programme et donc ça c'est
extrêmement important et je crois que
depuis des années mais ce n'est pas
propre à l'école je pense c'est propre à
toutes les organisations notamment dans
le domaine du privé on a un séparatisme
grandissant entre la direction les
directions et puis les exécutants ceux
qui sont face à l'élève face à
consommateurs ceux qui travaillent vous
avez d'un côté les directions qu'ils
pensent avec des chiffres qui parlent
agilité qui veulent changer le système
qui ont des grandes idées pédagogique
pour le cas de l'éducation nationale et
puis en face vous avez la réalité du
terrain et quand les professeurs
remontait cette réalité à leur proviseur
à leur recteur on leur disait pas de
vagues
je crois que ça suffit c'est partout
pareil quand c'était à france télécom il
ya eu des vagues de suicides ce
séparatisme delà des directions doit
cesser aujourd'hui c'est les gens au
front ce qu'ils sont face élèves ceux
qui sont les soignants faso covin cela
qu'on doit écouter ceux là qui doivent
décider et arrêter avec ce management
par parle par le tableau excel pas par
le par le chiffrer par l'idéologie parce
que derrière le fait d'avoir lâché les
professeurs depuis tant d'années fait
qu'on arrive à cet extrême et c'est
terrible parce que oui ça ça a pu être
une bonne chose à un moment de faire
entrer les parents d'élèves à l'école
pour qu'il y ait un dialogue pourquoi on
rencontre les professeurs pour qu'on
comprenne comment se faisait l'éducation
des enfants à l'école mais un moment
l'école de la république elle n'a pas
ouvrir ses portes pour tout le monde et
je crois qu'elle est suffisamment bien
fait pour continuer à former à éduquer à
élever les futurs citoyens que sont les
jeunes élèves
donc il faut maintenant changer la
l'inversion de la courbe de de la façon
dont ont été gérés le management au sein
des des rectorats et faire que les
professeurs soient entendues et puisse à
nouveau reprendre le pouvoir
pour la suite des cours et l'éducation
telle qu'elle doit être faite
aujourd'hui et protéger jacques
milliards effectivement il ya cette
question de la place des parents dans
l'enseignement dans les écoles de la
république qui est qu'est ce que vous en
pensez quelle relation
aujourd'hui l'école doit-elle à avoir
avec les parents la relation professeurs
parents comment est ce qu'elle voit
évoluer la question des parents dans
l'école tout l'est pas les parents
d'élèves ont été pires mais facile mais
en l'occurrence ça n'a rien à voir
ici on est dans un cas véritablement où
vous avez des intégristes religieux qui
veulent imposer leur loi au mépris des
lois de la république
je le redis les écoles ce collège comme
d'autres sont le reflet de la société et
doivent accueillir les enfants le
problème c'est que nous avons des
enfants qui veulent imposer leur loi
parce que ils sont dans une mouvance
islamique qui est directement contraire
à l'enseignement français donc il faut
d'abord commencer si vous voulez ramener
dans la sérénité dans les écoles il faut
commencer par amener de la sérénité et
des sanctions dans ses banlieues
et c'est là où on doit prendre des
sanctions car on voit bien aujourd'hui
dans cette enquête qu'il ya eu un
certain nombre d'intégrés systémique qui
tenait des propos qu'ils véhiculaient
des convictions qui sont directement
contraires à l'ordonnancement juridique
français et c'est là où il faut les
expulser très rapidement et pour
expulser aujourd'hui il faut modifier
légèrement à la constitution française
car on est dans une complexité sans nom
où c'est en définitive ça dure des
années des années
avec certains avocats qui disent c'est
le moment de pouvoir agir et d'avoir un
fonds de commerce
il faut que les expulsions pour tous ces
gens là qui tiennent des propos
contraires à l'ordre public français
soit d expulsion administrative sous la
juridiction administrative et il faut
modifier la constitution sur ce point
ensuite il faut contrôler nos frontières
parce que aujourd'hui on a des
frontières qui notamment permettent à
chaque individu d'arriver sur le
territoire français très facilement de
demander la protection des conventions
de genève d'être réfugié politique
et avant que ça ne soit juge et ça dure
des années donc il est il est manifeste
que nous accueillons aujourd'hui sur le
territoire français des gens qui sont
absolument pas dans l'ordre juridique
français et il ya un moment il faut
arrêter
nous avons été naïfs collectivement je
laisse bercer un élément fort allez-y
et on entendra ensuite noah manoir à
policiers délégué syndical visite du
haras rejoint en mai 2003 j'ai participé
avec président jean louis debré a une
mission d'information sur la laïcité à
l'école
en 2003 déjà nous avions entendu des
appels au secours des professeurs nous
disons on ne peut plus enseigner
correctement on ne peut plus parler des
religions parce que certains dès qu'on
parle de l'islam y avait des revenus en
disant toi tu n'es pas musulmane tu dois
pas nous parler de l'islam de parler de
la shoah donc on a laissé faire on a
crié et moi je me souviens que j'avais
été l'un des premiers à organiser à
l'assemblée nationale un forum sur la
laïcité on sait très bien que ça a duré
pendant des années et qu'on a laissé
pourrir la situation
ce qui n'est pas acceptable alors on va
revenir du côté de l'anc est avec vous
noah manoir vous nous avez rejoint vous
êtes policier délégué syndical vie
j bonsoir alors trois jours après
l'attentât de conflans on le disait 15
personnes en garde à vue quatre
collégiens contact entre le tueur et des
parents d'élèves qui dénonçaient les
caricatures on apprend également que le
terroriste a distribué de l'argent aux
collégiens en échange de renseignements
sur le professeur assassiné on a la
sensation effectivement que derrière
tout ça il y à un réseau enfin en tout
cas une nébuleuse
dans le même temps une note des
renseignements qui a pu consulter arte
france qui indique qu'au sein du collège
aucune tension majeure n'est palpable
qu'est ce que vous en pensez de tout ça
noah manoir alors permettez-moi de
rectifier votre propos j'ai pu consulter
la note du renseignement territoriales à
aucun moment la note ne précise qu
aucune tension n'est palpable au sein du
collège
effectivement la note se veut optimiste
quant à une possibilité de résolution de
conflits suite à des excuses qui avait
été prononcée par l'enseignant suite à
une médiation qui avait été initiée par
la responsable d'établissement entre des
parents et enseignants mais à aucun
moment le renseignement territoriale ne
prévoit une est formel sur un apaisement
des tensions ou du conflit ensuite
effectivement il ya peut-être un défaut
de recommandation de la part des
services de police quant à la mise en
place d'une protection pour cet
enseignant
quant à peut-être une éventuelle
exclusion des élèves et des éléments
perturbateurs donc écouté il ya
peut-être effectivement des prospectives
qui ont manqué de la part des analystes
du service départemental de
renseignement territoriale ensuite
écouté on peut pas refaire le match je
dirais après coup c'est ce qui est
arrivé est arrivé il faut en tirer les
conclusions mais est ce qu on veut
parler c'est quoi c'est un réseau ou
alors c'est un un enchaînement de faits
finalement qui ont amené à ce drame
écoutez moi j'ai eu la particularité au
moment de mon exercice de au sein du
renseignement territoriale 93 de suivre
monsieur sefrioui en 2009 c'est à dire
que c'est quelqu'un qui n'est absolument
pas un inconnu pour les services de
police si j'étais amené à croiser demain
il me reconnaîtrait parfaitement et je
le connais parfaitement
c'est quelqu'un qui n'a jamais changé de
cap c'est à dire c'est quelqu'un qui a
toujours manifesté un antisémitisme et
antisionisme une hostilité à la
république française de façon
extrêmement virulente c'est quelqu'un
qui a
adopter cette attitude sweet suite à la
nommer à son décret en fait de
naturalisation qu'il a obtenue par
mariage avec une femme d'origine franco
françaises converties à l'islam
donc c'est quelqu'un qui a manifesté une
certaine arrogance en fait à l'encontre
de la république puisque une fois qui
s'est senti en sécurité de part
justement sa naturalisation
il a manifesté des propos anti
républicain il a même eu une influence
très néfaste sur la jeunesse française à
travers des vecteurs numérique à travers
des manifestations organisées sur la
voie publique à travers également des
prières organisées dans la rue à des
défis ouvert lancé à des élus
républicains
il a entre autres tenté de déstabiliser
un certain nombre de chefs
d'établissements comme à saint-ouen j
étais moi-même j'étais en charge de ce
dossier
j'étais là le soir ou à montreuil il a
organisé un pugilat en règle avec des
jeunes banlieusards pour terroriser
devant les caméras de télévision des ddd
élus dont manuel valls à l'époque où il
était député jean pierre brard à
montreuil
des militantes des confédération
étudiante et de ni ni soumises
dont qui ont été violentés c'est à dire
que des hommes ont frappé des femmes au
visage et à dire à coups de poing de
façon très violente sur ordre de ce
monsieur à l'époque on a entamé
également des procédures judiciaires à
la mairie d'epinay sur seine
ils avaient organisé des prières de rue
contre monsieur avait chevreau qui était
maire d'epinay sur seine et qui avait
décidé d'octroyer un local municipal à
la mosquée de paris pour y créer une
mosquée républicaine donc et il s'est
jamais rien passé entre temps c'est à
dire que il ya une procédure judiciaire
qui ont été initiés on a intenté mon
chef de service moi même et le préfet
lambert à l'époque une tentative pour
déchoir de sa nationalité française ce
monsieur et je constate avec dépit que
onze ans plus tard
ce monsieur est toujours là et j'ai pas
besoin de vous rappeler les faits de
vendredi dernier
mais si vous voulez moi je j'avais
décidé de pas m'exprimer sur ce dossier
parce que je vais pas redire ce que j'ai
toujours dit en tout cas dans un manoir
des mesures gérard maintenant vient de
demander la fermeture de la mosquée de
pantin
alexis poulains avant de vous donner la
parole je vous propose de regarder la
réaction ce matin du ministre de
l'intérieur
je vais proposer la dissolution du cci
eef et de baraka city des associations
ennemis de la république
il faut arrêter d'être naïf et voir la
vérité en face
il n'y a aucun accommodement possible
avec l'islamisme radical tout compromis
est une compromission
voilà donc plusieurs mesures annoncées
alexis poulain c'est la réponse qu'on
attend est ce que ces réponses sont à la
hauteur de la situation selon vous on
espère je crois qu'aujourd'hui c'est un
héritage de toutes ces années de
démission d'accommodement avec cet
islamisme qui permettait d'entrer par
toutes les porte qui était entrouverte
les parents d'élèves qui poussait pour
faire entrer leur foi dans l'école de la
république et puis on les écoutait avec
bienveillance on était toujours ouvert
au dialogue mais c'était un dialogue
finalement qui a été utilisé à des fins
politiques donc aujourd'hui si la
politique reprend ses droits
enfin et que les lois sont utilisés et
que dans le cadre du droit on peut
lutter contre ce poison et contre ceux
qui sèment le poison dans l'esprit des
jeunes parce que je veux bien on entend
c'est la faute des réseaux sociaux non
c'est la faute de ces prédicateurs de
haine c'est la faute de ces gens qui
année après année on fait de l'islam une
arme ont fait de l'islam quelque chose
qui allait à l'encontre de d'un principe
de religion de concorde et ceux là
doivent être attaqués et parce que c'est
une question de vie ou de mort
maintenant de la république alors les
grands discours
on en a entendu beaucoup emmanuel macron
veut terroriser les terroristes ils
veulent qu'ils ne dorment plus
tranquille aujourd'hui c'est plutôt les
français qui ne dorment pas tranquille
ne sachant pas si quand ils mettent
leurs enfants à l'école
tout va bien se passer donc il faut
vraiment mettre les moyens et les moyens
ça veut dire de l'argent encore une fois
arrêter de faire croire qu'à pharos avec
28 personnes dédiées aux la surveillance
des réseaux sociaux ça peut fonctionner
non il en faut peut-être 100 fois plus
pareil avec la façon dont on a traité
cesser ces imams radicaux avec
complaisance ça suffit je crois que on
ne peut pas tolérer sur le territoire
français un des
finalement des ennemis de la république
qui passent leur temps à instiller un
poison qui va jusqu'à pousser au meurtre
certains certains jeunes même si en
l'occurrence c'était un jeune tchétchène
mais voilà le problème nous avons
affaire ici à une idéologie politique
internationale en dehors des frontières
mais qui est bien l'utiliser à des fins
politiques pour déstabiliser la
république donc il est temps que la
république se défendent et j'espère que
la réponse oui sera à la hauteur mais là
encore reste à voir ce reste des
propositions on parle de deux
associations enfin je crois que c'est
une soixantaine en réalité 231 fichier
est ce qu'ils seraient raccompagnés à la
frontière toutes les obligations de
quitter le territoire français j'espère
vont cette fois ci être mise en exercice
pour les radicaliser a minima et voilà
ce qu'on est ce qu'on aimerait voir et
entendre dans les semaines qui viennent
pour que enfin cesse ce poison permanent
de l'islamisme sur notre territoire
jacques milliards en quelques mots ce
matin marine le pen a parlé de
défaillance administrative le tueur
était d'origine tchétchène ont la dînée
à moscou il avait un titre de séjour
délivré le 4 mars dernier
est ce que les services de l'état ont
fauté selon vous écoutez quand j'entends
notre ami policier
je suis stupéfait parce que ya pas une
histoire il ya une protohistoire il est
évident qu'il ya eu manipulation par cet
homme là sur les réseaux est ce parce
que vous savez c'est une manipulation
qu'est ce que cette l'islam radical
c'est une conception du monde qui vous
apprennent totalement c'est qu'une quasi
secte et il malheureusement dans
l'histoire de l'islam c'est récurrent
depuis des siècles ou régulièrement il y
a malheureusement une vision une
interprétation du livre qui est celle ci
est donc il ya rien de bien nouveau à
mes yeux nous ce qui est évident c'est
que bien sûr cet individu est entré sur
le territoire
je dirais dans un milieu qui était un
milieu radical et qu'on aurait dû y
regarder à deux fois mais quand
j'entends notre ami policier nous
raconter tout ce qu'il laissait sur
l'individu qui a monté en puissance à
travers les réseaux et qu'il n'a pas été
sanctionné qu'il n'a pas été déçu de
sable
ce n'était française alors là je dis oui
il ya un dysfonctionnement le mot de la
fin
le mot de la fin pour vous noah manoir
emmanuel macron a dit le soir du drame
la peur doit changer de camp
oui mais comment à écouter aujourd'hui
on pose la question à savoir si on a
fait le bon diagnostic concernant la
situation de cet enseignant et si on
avait dû prendre des mesures on aurait
dû l'entouré en permanence de 2 3 4 ou
peut-être une dizaine de policiers munis
de pistolets automatiques etc savez en
démocratie c'est absolument pas normal
qu'une personne qui va au travail le
matin puis 7 contre achat se déplaçait
avec une armée de policiers autour
d'elle
je pense que dans une société normale ce
serait justement à ces criminels d'avoir
un pistolet ou un fusil mitrailleur
pointé en permanence pour surveiller
leur moindre faux pas malheureusement
c'est pas comme ça que ça se passe dans
la france de 2020 merci à tous les trois
merci à vous alexis poulain je rappelle
que vous êtes éditorialistes merci à
vous jacques milliard mer les
républicains de maisons laffitte dans
les yvelines
merci à vous noah manoir délégué
syndical vichy est resté avec nous sur
rt france dans quelques instants nous
reviendrons sur la situation sanitaire
en france alors que le couvre-feu est en
vigueur en ile-de-france et dans le
métropole depuis le week-end dernier
et puis nous parlerons du brics its
londres et bruxelles discutent du format
de leurs négociations mais sont toujours
dans l'impasse a tout de suite sur rt
france
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes
mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
pieds coût politique a jamais été obligé
de dire la veille mais idée courageuse
des mots qui comptent en soi vient de
l'ignorance
aujourd'hui une gauche plus que 13 ans
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue sur rt france si
vous nous rejoignez il est 20h30 heure
française à la lune ce soir l'assassinât
de soi mais elle pâtit à conflans sainte
honorine une nouvelle attaque qui
intervient en plein procès des attentats
de janvier 2015
le point avec notre reporter katia
technique depuis le tribunal de paris
beaucoup d'émotion au tribunal
aujourd'hui après la deuxième attaque
depuis le début du procès ce matin le
président et des avocats des parties
civiles ont pris la parole pour rendre
hommage à samuel pâtit je vous propose
d'écouter et richard malka avocat de
charlie hebdo
ils s'en prennent à tous les fondements
de la république et à tout le monde
ils ont tué des juifs ils ont tué des
musulmans ils ont tué des chrétiens ils
tuent tout le monde
ils ce sont les fanatiques islamistes ce
sont les fascistes islamistes
ils n'ont pu prospérer que grâce à cette
arme de destruction massive de notre
république que sont les accusations
d'islamophobie constante que sont la
culpabilisation la victimisation
constante
là c'est cette rhétorique de
l'humiliation en inventant des faits
comme l'a fait ce père de famille qui
appelait à la haine
dans une vidéo et dans la fille n'était
même pas dans le cours qu'elle est allée
auquel elle était censée avoir assisté
tout ça on le connaît y ait 50 rapport
et on n'a rien fait aujourd'hui l'accusé
médecine carassou l'art a été entendu il
ferait partie d'une filière d'armes
belge il disposait d'un garage en
belgique à mehdi coulibaly s'est rendue
plusieurs fois officiellement pour
l'achat d'une voiture mais un prix
tellement bas qu'on suspecte un trafic
d'armes
émétine carassou l'arle ni même si on a
retrouvé des listes avec des prix et des
armes
il dit qu'il faisait partie plutôt du
pkk et qu'il était contre des chais
qu'il était dans des cercles de jeux et
non dans la vente d'armes
je vous propose d'écouter son avocat
jean chevais moi je crois depuis le
début que ce garçon est innocent et l'un
a fait la démonstration ce matin
en partant de façon très ému et très
honnête parce que il a dit qu'il était
contre ce genre de crime et que jamais
de sa vie ne pourrait faire ça qu'il a
cinq enfants et ils condamnent de façon
très ferme
les attentats et lui c'est un petit
grade qui fait un peu des du trafic de
voitures du trafic de stupéfiants et qui
prend un petit billet par ci un billet
par là et avec un vent dans une voiture
mais ça ne fait pas de lui un terroriste
ça fait pas de lui un coupable difficile
d'évaluer une éventuelle culpabilité
tant médecine carrasso l'art est revenu
sur ses propos et à des moments
d'amnésie les témoins n'ont pas vraiment
permis non plus de comprendre réellement
ce qu'il s'est passé
et d'ailleurs c'est une constante dans
ce procès de nombreuses zones nombre
empêche de comprendre la séquence des
événements la situation sanitaire en
france à présent et un point sur les
derniers chiffres santé publique france
dénombre treize mille deux cent quarante
trois nouvelles contaminations aux kobe
dans 24 heures
cent quarante six personnes sont
décédées à l'hôpital
le taux de positivité des tests
s'établit désormais à 13 4%
au total le nombre de morts s'élève à 33
1623 personnes et pour en parler nous
sommes avec thierry lardeux noah médecin
généraliste président de la carmf c'est
la caisse autonome de retraite des
médecins de france membre du collectif
laissons les prescrire
thierry lardinoit merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors pour
commencer votre réaction peut-être sur
le nombre de contaminations plus de
32000 ce week-end cela peut faire peur
mais ça avant tout finalement parce que
nous testons en masse oui
incontestablement
on se rend compte que le nombre de tests
positifs est en augmentation parce que
le nombre de tests est en augmentation
ça ne signifie pas en soi que l'épidémie
soit en explosion complète
j'en veux pour preuve que si on regarde
la mortalité en france entre le début de
l'épidémie la france était quatrième sur
la totalité des pays et où nous sommes
maintenant le neuvième pays en termes de
mortalité
on a donc bien reculer de façon très
importante en termes de mortalité
ce qui prouve bien que l'épidémie est
différente elle est absolument
différente depuis le depuis le début
donc oui on teste beaucoup oui on a
beaucoup de positif
pour autant on ne voit pas une explosion
comme on l'a vu au mois de mars et des
hospitalisations et des réanimations et
d'équidés décès malheureusement qu'il
équipe a pu revenir donc l'épidémie et
là on en a la preuve par tous ces tests
vous parlez d'une épidémie différentes
en quoi ce n'est pas la même pour vous
que la première vague alors là c'est la
façon de la traiter
il ya plus grave dans ses aspects il ya
l'aspect que quand on quand on regarde
les fameuse courbe en cloche
si vous regardez la courbe en cloche de
la première de cette première vague de
cette seule vague en fait c'est une
vraie courbe en cloche qui est
importante avec une ascension brutale du
nombre de morts une ascension brutale
des patients hospitalisés et je rappelle
que cette ascension brutal se produit
sur pratiquement seulement trois grandes
régions - c'est pas c'est pas sur
l'ensemble de la france
quand on regarde aujourd'hui l'évolution
des chiffres on est sur la totalité de
la france maintenant il n'y a plus de
régions qu'ils soient et ils m'ont
épargné toute la france est touchée et
on voit que c'est attendre sept
ascensions étaient très lentes on n'est
pas face à une courbe qui monte
brutalement on est face à une courbe qui
monte doucement
alors quand on regarde sur les épidémies
d'origine saisonnière et d'origine
pulmonaire on a en ce qui concerne ces
épidémies et je pense particulièrement à
la grippe mais les autres c'est
également un cas ce qu'on appelle des
répliques
c'est à dire que dans un premier temps
on voit
grosse épidémie qui arrive par exemple
pour la grippe on voit ça en décembre
janvier
et puis vous voyez des petites répliques
en mars avril mai où quelques cas
peuvent apparaître de nouveau j'ai
l'impression j'ai l'impression est bon
je suis pas l'épidémiologiste mais qu'on
est un petit peu sur cette logique là
avec des répliques et sur une sur une
maladie qui incontestablement n'a pas
tout à fait la dangerosité qu'elle avait
à la première phase la politique des
tests pour pour y revenir et ce qu'elle
a progressé selon vous mais si vous
voulez là vous parlez vous dites bien
une chose qui est très intéressant dans
votre propos je vous dis que la
politique c'est à dire que s est ce une
décision politique ou est ce une
décision médicale
moi en tant que médecin je ne considère
pas que les tests en open source en open
bar je dirais un petit peu soit la
meilleure des solutions
mais on peut parfaitement comprendre que
cette décision soit une décision de
nature politique et qu'il était
important pour le politique de faire
cette offre sur le plan médical
épidémiologique sa nécessité
et ça ça comment son utilité me
paraissent un petit peu plus discutable
alors le couvre-feu en tout cas dans les
grandes métropoles a commencé vendredi
soir à minuit quand est-ce qu'on pourra
véritablement observer s'il amène la
méthode fonctionne ou pas on dit on dit
qu'il ya toujours un décalage entre
alors les indices sept jours les autres
10 15 jours qu'il ya toujours un
décalage mais habituellement le dirai à
peu près de à peu près de sept jours
pour voir pour voir l'efficacité de
cette méthode sur le terrain comment ça
se passe chez vous docteur comment dans
votre cabinet
vous vivez cette épidémie est ce que
vous avez un flux permanent de patients
aujourd'hui alors sur le plan pratique
moi je suis dans le grand est
on voit non par un flux permanent mais
on voit arriver quelques quelques cas où
peut pas le on peut pas le contester
mais qui pour l'instant sont tous plus
tôt plutôt bien ne je ne constate pas de
cas graves
je ne constate pas de calais alors vous
le disiez vous êtes dans le grand test
on sait qu'il ya beaucoup souffert alors
de la première vague là une région
plutôt épargnée jusqu'ici comment est ce
que vous le comprenez comment est ce que
vous les expliquer alors vous dites
épargné il semblerait qu'on repasse dans
le rouge lors j'ai pas toutes les
explications de ce passage dans le rouge
mouais moi j'ai l'impression que chez
nous la vague a été violent parce qu'on
était les premiers on a été les tout
premiers à subir si vous le subir c'est
arrivé donc on n'était peut-être pas
tout à fait tout à fait organiser tout à
fait prêt j'ai l'impression
qu'aujourd'hui le tissu médical est un
petit peu plus organisé un petit peu
plus disponibles et on a peut-être un
petit peu tirer les leçons de la
première partie où on avait mis en
retrait la totalité du monde médical il
fallait vraiment que les hôpitaux soient
seul et unique en première ligne face on
dit j'ai vu c'est que les autres soient
tous en retrait personne ne bouge et on
s'aperçoit aujourd'hui que le monde
médical dans son entier est au travail
donc les médecins généralistes dont je
fais partie mais également tous mes
confrères spécialistes neurologues
gastro entérologue et c'est tout
toutes les professions tous les
professionnels de santé sont au travail
face à leurs patients et que nous
prenons en charge tout ce qu'il est
possible de prendre en charge et que de
ce fait la malle sommes manifestement on
réduit ont réduit l'intensité des
l'intensité de la crise alors une
campagne de vaccination contre la grippe
a débuté la semaine dernière ce que vous
vous constatez une demande importante de
de vaccination ces derniers jours quel
est votre regard sur sur justement cette
stratégie à la demande de vaccination
est absolument massif massive les les
pharmacies sont totalement dévalisé
actuellement il n'y a pas possibilité de
vacciner en ce moment des gens en dehors
de ceux qui ont reçu les documents de la
sécurité sociale qui leur permettait
d'avoir d'avoir le vaccin gratuitement
donc et du coup ça veut dire qu'on
pourrait craindre une pénurie de vaccins
contre la grippe également
c'est un scénario envisageable non non
ça je ne pense pas moi je donne quitus
quand même aux pouvoirs publics d'être
d'être compétent sur la gestion de ce
type de stocks parce qu'il ya quand même
des habitudes anciennes sur la gestion
de la grippe et ils ont la réflexion qui
est tout à fait logique de privilégier
les populations à risque mon premier pan
parce que c'est celle qui risque d'avoir
de gros ennuis si jamais ils cumulent
une grille t1 corona donc c'est cela qui
est privilégié c'est cela que nous
privilégions nous sur le terrain
également
et je pense que ça va très très bien se
passer je pense que ça va très très bien
se passer
alors on a man le convive 19 on vit avec
jusqu'à l'été prochain au moins alors on
lis pas dans le marc de café
mais moi par essence je suis je suis
optimiste je suis d'une famille de
médecins j'ai la médecine chevillée au
corps
moi je suis convaincu de ressentir des
signes de l'amélioration de la situation
et du fait que nous allons pouvoir venir
à bout de à bout de cette épidémie dans
un délai qui à mon avis est plus
raisonnable que l'été prochain
merci beaucoup thierry lardinoit d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes médecin généraliste et
président de la caisse autonome de
retraite des médecins de france mais
également membre du collectif laissons
les prescrire et comment en france lé
renforcement des mesures face au rebond
du comité 19 se multiplient un peu
partout en europe avec plus de 8000
morts recensés en sept jours l'europe
doit serrer la vis tour d'horizon de ces
nouvelles mesures en images
[Musique]
e
j'en peux plus quoi mam nous serveur ou
responsables ou cuisiniers aux plongeurs
tout le monde souffre c'est horrible je
crois que on est une grande famille on
essaie de soutenir mais là je crois
vraiment que les choses vont changer
parce qu on en a vraiment ras le bol
énorme et ça peut plus continuer surtout
je me sens particulièrement la tristesse
pour ce milieu qu'on
qui coule et on sent vraiment c'est
l'urgence pour c'est très dommage
[Musique]
il
si tu vas être aurions nous besoin de
plus de contrôle sur le terrain au lieu
de puissants décret juste écrit sur le
papier il y a eu moins de clients à
cause du télétravail nos clients
réguliers continuent de venir plus ou
moins bien sûr il n'ya plus de tourisme
et de nombreux bureaux sont fermés
[Musique]
oui
il
[Musique]
et on en vient aux briques site est
toujours pas d'accord entre l'union
européenne et le royaume uni les deux
parties se sont retrouvées aujourd'hui
pour discuter du format des négociations
mais les désaccords subsistent michel
barnier négociateur en chef pour l'union
européenne dit aujourd'hui que les
vingt-sept sont disponibles pour
négocier pour londres négociée n'a pas
de sens faute de changement de politique
de l'ua à mai s'est dit de tout de même
ouvert à la négociation
l'ombre du no deal elle plane toujours
écouter à ce sujet le vice président de
la commission européenne bien sûr nous
nous concentrerons sur la conclusion
d'un bon accord entre l'union européenne
et le royaume uni qui comme nous l'avons
souligné doit être équitable pour les
deux parties nous n'allons pas signer un
accord à n'importe quel prix mais nous
aurons la discussion entre les
négociateurs en chef cet après-midi et
l'union européenne est prête à
travailler jusqu'à la dernière minute
pour obtenir un bon accord pour les deux
parties et pour en parler nous sommes
avec claude blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales
l'autre blanche maison bercy d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france bonsoir
alors bruxelles et londres discutent du
jeu site format de leurs négociations
que recouvre ce terme et bien c'est
l'expression d'un embarras un embarras
puisque en effet la négociation piétine
maintenant depuis plusieurs mois et que
tout le monde dit à chaque réunion il
faut accélérer la négociation
michel barnier a appelé son homologue
d'abord au téléphone david frost et lui
a dit accélérons la négociation et david
frost lui a répondu en anglais sans
doute bien entendu accélérons la
négociation mais l'union européenne doit
d'abord changer sa position et barnier a
répondu non c'est évidemment au royaume
uni de changer sa position donc dialogue
de sourds dialogue de sourds au niveau
de la négociation
et ceci pour deux raisons la première
raison c'est que on se bat sur des
principes et pas sur des choses
concrètes et la deuxième raison c'est
que l'un comme l'autre les deux camps
ont choisi
la stratégie du tout ou rien alors on se
base sur les principes et la stratégie
du tout ou rien par exemple pour la
pêche
l'un des sujets les plus sensibles et
plus les plus difficiles et bien l'union
européenne dit maintien en l'état des
droits de pêche des pêcheurs européens
dans les eaux britanniques
naturellement la grande bretagne sur
écrit souveraineté britannique
nous accorderons cas par cas des droits
de pêche qui seront ou pas renouvelable
chaque année
même chose pour les conditions de
concurrence bruxelles dit bien sûr ne
pouvons pas accepter le dumping social
du dumping fiscal un dumping
environnemental
il faut long que nous ayons un droit de
regard sur les aides que londres
pourrait accorder des entreprises en
écosse en irlande du nord ou ailleurs et
bien entendu londres répond souveraineté
nationale pas question de bruxelles se
mêle de ça même chose pour la pour la
gestion de l'accord pour le règlement
des contentieux au brussels diva il
s'agit de droit communautaire par
conséquent c'est la cour de justice de
l'union européenne qui statuera et bien
entendu londres 10 banos puisque nous
sommes sortis de l'union européenne
ça ne peut pas être un organe de l'union
européenne qui serait pour peut être
juge et partie donc on en est là et tout
le monde continue de dire marchon et
accélérant la cadence
alors ce matin le vice président de la
commission européenne maros sefcovic a
rencontré michael gove
la présence de marc aux deux maros
sefcovic qu'est ce qu'elle signifie
alors le motif officiel de la venue de
maros sefcovic
à londres c'est de discuter avec son
homologue c'est à dire le ministre
britannique qui est michael koch qui est
en charge de la coordination de toutes
les affaires interministérielle qui est
l'un des ministres les plus importants
auprès de de boris johnson 2
de la question de la du projet de loi du
gouvernement britannique qui s'il était
adopté risquerait de mettre en cause un
élément du traité du bric site
1 le premier traité du mexique qui a été
signé et ratifié en décembre dernier et
qui prévoit dans une annexe relatives à
l'irlande
des dispositions qui font qu'il ne
pourrait pas y avoir rétablissement
d'une frontière entre l'irlande du nord
et la république d'irlande
or si ce texte sur le marché intérieur
britannique était adopté il est
actuellement devant les lords et
apparemment avec quelques difficultés et
bien ceux ci pourraient aboutir au
rétablissement de cette frontière ce qui
serait évidemment grave ici mais le
vice-président de la commission semble
avoir évoqué avec michael moore michael
gove
d'autres sujets et la négociation dans
son ensemble puisqu'ils ont l'un comme
l'autre dit qu' il était plutôt
optimiste sur la suite de la négociation
et que tous les sujets avaient été
débloqués qu'on pouvait faire des
progrès sur tous les sujets qui étaient
sur la table donc 200 de cloche un petit
peu différent et avec en effet un
nouveau venu finalement dans la
négociation mccovey un homme politique
britannique d'une grande expérience il a
été plusieurs fois candidat pour diriger
le parti le parti conservateur et il
était partisan du break si bien sûr il
est très proche de boris johnson
mais boris johnson l'a battu à chaque
fois lorsqu'il a voulu être président du
parti conservateur
il a sans doute une influence très
importante et probablement qu'il est
aussi en contact avec les milieux
d'affaires britanniques qui comme vous
le savez volt un accord bien entendu
donc c'est quelque chose d'important
le vice-président de la commission est
un commissaire d'origine slovaque
il a été représentant permanent de la
slovaquie auprès l'union européenne des
glaces slovaque est devenu membre de
l'union européenne en 2004
ensuite il devenu commissaire en 2009 et
c'est donc un très grand spécialiste de
la mécanique européenne
alors le temps presse pour les deux
parties cela peut conduire à un accord
ou au contraire à un odile d'après vous
les deux voies sont ouvertes mais pour
parvenir à un accord
comme je viens de le suggérer il faut se
changer la méthode si on continue à se
battre sur des principes et à rester
dans la dans la logique du tout ou rien
il est clair qu'on aboutira à un audit
c'est un choix des deux côtés c'est un
choix politique
il est possible aussi des gens sérieux
se met s'attelle à la négociation
en termes concrets d'aboutir à des
accords après tout sur la pêche de quoi
parle-t-on
on parle de l'accès à des zones de pêche
dans les eaux britanniques et de quotas
de poisson espèce par espèce que les
pêcheurs européens pourraient amener du
côté européen c'est quelque chose de
très concret de trade très austère
d'ailleurs mais on n'est pas du tout
rentrer dans cette négociation pour le
moment c'est la même chose finalement
pour les risques de dumping
les aides aux entreprises britanniques
bien sûr il existe des règles générales
en dehors de l'union européenne les
règles de l'os et 2 par exemple
et il est sans doute possible d'imaginer
un système qui garantirait l'union
européenne contre le dumping éventuel
des autorités britanniques
sans se soumettre à la commission aux
fourches caudines de la commission et
puis pour gérer l'accord et bien après
tout tous les accords internationaux ont
une commission mixte qui gère l'accord
donc il est là aussi possible de trouver
des solutions dans le cadre de deux
commissions paritaires
merci beaucoup claude blanche maison
pour votre éclairage
je rappelle que vous êtes expert en
relations internationales est resté avec
nous dans quelques instants nous
reviendrons sur l'attentât qui a tué
l'enseignant semelle pâti à conflans
sainte honorine
un hommage national lui sera rendu ce
mercredi dans la cour de la sorbonne et
puis nous parlerons de la situation
sanitaire en france et des soignants
première ligne alors que la deuxième
vague accentuer encore un malaise déjà
existants a tout de suite sur rt france
dans les banques où la diversité c'est
notre point fort pas notre point faible
ce que j'ai vu depuis le 17 octobre et
depuis aussi le 4 août c'est une
mobilisation sociétal qui n'existait pas
avant toutes les confessions se
retrouver sur la place des martyrs un
certain chouhada et tout le monde
discute est finalement que mon discuter
ils sont trouvés entre le même drapeau
libanais pour une fois voyez des images
assez touchants de l'armée qui était
presque impliqué avec les manifestants
aujourd'hui on sent que le ton a changé
c'est la cause des hommes politiques et
sont en train de manipuler l'armée on
sait très bien pourquoi ils nous tirent
dessus sais pas s'ils savent que c'est
leur fin ils se préparent le seul
langage qu'ils connaissaient la violence
ne va pas être violent mais on va rester
un des sujets les plus préoccupants du
moment et celui de l'otan et de la
défense ont donné tout au long des
années l'alliance atlantique s'est
investi dans des guerres qui n'étaient
pas toujours réellement en ligne avec
ses objectifs tels que la situation
s'est aggravée avec le début d' attaques
contre la frégate courbet 10 juillet les
mots nations contre la grèce et la
présence de thua d'ist syriens venus
d'idlib haut karabakh
incapable de régler ses conflits
internes le temps est devenu un frein
politique à l'unité européenne
c'est à l'europe d'être en capacité
d'assumer la responsabilité de sa propre
sécurité et d'agir de manière autonome
quand c'est nécessaire mais compte tenu
des divergences avec l europe pourront
nous le faire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je ne peux pas
écoutez moi tout le monde si vous faites
trop de bruit je vais vous renvoyer dans
la salle de classe entendu certaines
personnes n'aiment pas le cirque
nous devons éveiller l'intérêt pour le
cirque chez les adultes et les enfants
pour les inciter à venir et à apprendre
[Musique]
eh bien eh bien l'or fait d'une main et
rattraper avec l'autre
[Musique]
je joue à quoi joue est important pour
un an
il ya eu un bombardement récemment tout
le monde a été tuée femmes vieillards et
enfants
tout a été détruit il ya un monde à
l'extérieur
il en existe un autre ici à l'intérieur
de ses murs
[Musique]
le
nada tandis que personne n'a jamais
parcourues telle distance l'italien
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est oublier quelle étape
sert ce n'est pas un record guinness
pour rien dès les gens et les chiens
travail jusqu'aux limites de leurs
capacités
[Musique]
chose qu'on sent que les chiens sont
très fatigués des moi aussi je suis
épuisé
[Musique]
il a donc été contaminé par un enfant en
lui sauvant la vie
il m'a appelé pour la dernière fois
c'était mon anniversaire
il m'a dit maman par deux mois et c'est
un clip sio
je sais que mon père a contracté ce
virus à l'hôpital
il avait dit avoir transporté un
patients suspectés d'avoir locaux vides
et en amérique quand on dit suspecter
que cela signifie qu'ils ont le coc vide
elle a aimé cette personne pendant 44
ans
et le dernier message sur what's app
avait été envoyé dix minutes avant
qu'elle allait aux soins intensifs et
c'était un message à un patient qui
était malade et à lui expliquer quels
médicaments prendre
et en tant que maire j'ai pleuré parce
qu'il aurait dû se marier ce jour là au
lieu de cela ils étaient à l'hôpital
il a dit ses derniers mots et l'a dit il
a dit
[Musique]
je t'aime tellement je suis médecin moi
même je comprends ce qui m'arrive
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire comme tous les peuples
c'était une volonté collective vous le
savez comme moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative au sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers l'uniforme c'est quand
même des hommes comment ces mecs-là
arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi je
pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose
d'inusité gilet jaune c'était des
valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer qu une
sixième république qui ne soit pas un
oubli parlementaire ça se passe en
direct puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
la france n'est pas le seul pays qui a
eu des colonies dans le monde mais c'est
le seul qui refuse d'avancer qu'ils
refusent de s'adapter à l'air du temps
d'accepter un partenariat gagnant
gagnant avec ses anciennes colonies et
je constate aussi que c'est le seul pays
dont aucune et colonies n'a jamais été
développé comment faire en fait pour
établir cette relation gagnant gagnant
c'est pour nous africains de porter à la
tête de nous et à des gens qui sont
animés par la recherche dont intérêts de
leurs populations
[Musique]
bonsoir et merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'information il
est 21h heure de paris tout de suite
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
lundi 19 octobre 2002 l'enquète se
poursuit après l'assassinât de
l'enseignant samuel pâti à conflans
sainte honorine
le collectif contre l'islamophobie en
france est menacée de dissolution par le
gouvernement accusé de proximité avec l
islam politique l'association nie en
bloc et des noms je cite des calomnies
d'une incroyable indécence compte tenu
du contexte alors le ccf qui se dit
apolitique et areligieuse est il
impossible ennemis de la république
comme l'a décrit le ministre de
l'intérieur ce sera l'objet de notre
face à face le coronavirus pas
d'amélioration trop tôt encore pour
observer les effets du couvre feu entré
en vigueur le week-end dernier
ailleurs en europe la situation est tout
aussi inquiétante le pays de galles des
crêtes de semaine de confinement les
cafés et restaurants ferment leurs
portes ou un mois en belgique
angela merkel demande de restreindre les
relations sociales en allemagne
[Musique]
une nouvelle trêve sans effet dans le
haut-karabagh le cessez le feu entré en
vigueur samedi soir à minuit n'aura
nouveau tenu que quelques heures
et bakou et erevan s'accuse déjà
mutuellement de l'avoir violée les
membres du groupe de minsk coprésidé par
paris moscou et washington tentent tour
à tour de trouver des solutions aux
conflits aux états unis la pression
monte à deux semaines de l'élection
présidentielle joe biden était en
caroline du nord hier devant ses
partisans venus l'écouter il a entre
autres lancé un appel à l'électorat
froid américain sur lequel il compte
pour l'emporter dans cet état clé de son
côté dans le nevada donald trump a
défendu sa gestion de l'épidémie de
covin 19 taclant au passage le candidat
démocrate
[Musique]
et on débute avec les suites de
l'attentât islamiste de conflans sainte
honorine le gouvernement entend réagir
fort après l'assassinât de samuel pâtit
elle gérald darmanin vient de s'exprimer
chez nos confrères de tf1 on va tout de
suite retrouvé un autre reporter monaco
dès lors monaco jour vous êtes place
beauvau à paris alors qu'est ce que l'on
peut retenir de la prise de parole du
ministre de l'intérieur ce soir et bien
gérald darmanin elle fait part du plan
d'action pour lutter contre l'islam
radical la sidération doit changer de
camp ce sont elles les mots du ministre
de l'intérieur qui a d'ailleurs annoncé
est la fermeture d'une mosquée et
l'interpellation de son imam écouté le
ces opérations de police elles ont comme
but premier
faire que la sidération change de camp
les français ont été sidérés à la
décapitation par cet attentat islamiste
et nous devons aux français que la peur
la sidération change de camp et j'ai
demandé au préfet de seine-saint-denis
de faire fermer la mosquée de pantin
puisque son dirigeant a relayé le
message qui consiste effectivement à
dire que ce professeur devait être
intimidé en relayant d'ailleurs
l'adresse du collège
l'imam de cette mosquée a parmi ces
enfants déscolarisés dans l'école
interdite de la semaine dernière j'ai
fait fermer à bobigny où des enfants de
2 à 6 ans portait le hidjab en cours de
récréation sans fenêtre sans professeur
cette mosquée aujourd'hui sera fermé et
donc le préfet tincani sin ce soir son
interdiction
gérald darmanin qui va demander la
dissolution de deux associations
musulmanes baraka city et le ccf au
conseil des ministres ce sera donc à la
justice de trancher en réponse le ccf
vous l'avez dit a dénoncé des calomnies
à d'une incroyable l'indécence c'est le
gouvernement veut frapper plus fort
puisque plusieurs opérations policières
vont viser d'autres associations ou
d'autres individus pas forcément est
liée à l'attentât mais plutôt pour
intimider ceux qui veulent nous en
timide et ce sont les mots du ministre
de l'intérieur une cinquantaine
d'associations sont donc qu'on sait
mais lors de cette interview le ministre
de l'intérieur a également rappelé que
depuis 2010 7 356 lui ont radicalisé
avait été fermé et 411 étrangers et
fichier s avait été expulsé il s'agit
aussi de renforcer la surveillance
gérald darmanin a annoncé la création de
330 emplois supplémentaires dans les
services de renseignement pour le budget
2021 et enfin les patrons français des
réseaux sociaux sont également concernés
puisqu'ils seront convoqués et dès
demain par marlène schiappa dans le
cadre de la lutte contre le cyber
islamisme merci beaucoup
mona pour toutes ces précisions mona
hameau dès lors en direct de la place
beauvau fin on le disait le collectif
contre l'islamophobie en france est donc
menacée de dissolution par le
gouvernement accusé de proximité avec
l'islam politique l'association nie en
bloc et des noms je cite des calomnies
d'une incroyable indécence compte tenu
du contexte alors le ccf qui se dit
apolitique et areligieuse est il
impossible ennemis de la république
comme l'a décrit le ministre de
l'intérieur a c'est l'objet de notre
face à face et pour en débattre nous
sommes avec gaëtan du soc est membre du
conseil national du rassemblement
national bonsoir à vos côtés loïc
prud'hommes député la france insoumise
troisième circonscription de gironde
bonsoir
alors on le disait le ccf dans le
collimateur du gouvernement alors on va
le rappeler le collectif se présente
comme une association de défense des
droits humains et elle vise à lutter
contre l'islamophobie en apportant une
aide juridique aux personnes de victimes
d'actes islamophobes
alors quand le ministre de l'intérieur
parle du ccf comme d'un ennemi de la
république
est-ce que vous rejoignez ses propos
gaëtan du sausset mais je rejoins ses
propos et malheureusement ils sont un
peu tardif parce que gérald darmanin
est-ce que l'on peut regretter
et finalement comme le gouvernement et
le président de la république obligés
d'attendre qu'il y ait des morts obligés
d'attendre qu'il y est désastreux dette
atrocités pardon et des actes commis
avec une barbarie
ans pour prendre des décisions le ccf
c'est pas nouveau est à une organisation
qui est lié aux frères musulmans et
frères musulmans est une organisation
elle-même islamistes qui défend une
idéologie idéologie de fondamentalisme
islamiste et qui à de nombreuses
reprises déclaré
comment dire ont mis en avant un agenda
politique et aller complètement à
l'encontre de nos valeurs et à
l'encontre de notre pays
donc c'est très bien qu'il le fasse
maintenant il aurait peut-être fallu le
faire plus tôt mais malheureusement ça
ne suffira pareil dit oui il faut
dissoudre ccf oui il faut dissoudre
barak a city je pense qu'il faut aussi
se poser la question concernant d'autres
organisations contre liège mais même si
ces mesures sont sont bonnes il y en a
évidemment un tas d'autres qui va
falloir mettre en oeuvre par la suite
loïc prud'hommes
on se souvient que le 10 novembre 2010
2019 votre parti marcher aux côtés du
ccf pour dénoncer l'islamophobie
pour jean luc mélenchon le message
véhiculé par la manifestation était plus
important que les personnes qui
participaient est-ce que c'était une
erreur pour vous devrez rappeler que le
10 novembre nous marcher aux côtés de la
cgt de la fsu qui aujourd'hui appellent
au rassemblement autour de samuel pâtit
autour de attaque et autour de toute
cette gauche qui ne renonçait pas à
faire que les valeurs de la république
soit soit préservée comme matisse pas
une partie de notre population je
voudrais dire que pour moi généralement
darmanin se placent sur sur un terrain
qui est sur un registre qui n'est pas le
bon vous savez il ya une constante sur
les affaires de terrorisme c'est qu'il
faut quand on n'est pas responsable
politique agir avec sang-froid méthodes
et quand il fait des appels à dire la
peur doit changer de camp
il faut aussi des ré ceux qui nous ont
sidéré je voudrais rappeler que notre
force de la force de la république c'est
le respect du droit et donc il faut
absolument se placer dans ce respect de
la loi parce que sinon ça va être des
effets d'annoncé et in fine et je crains
que
tout ça n'aboutisse pas donc je pense
que nous avons l'arsenal suffisant 16
loi antiterroriste depuis 30 ans a fait
une tous les deux ans et il faut
maintenant scruter vraiment avec
attention toutes les associations et sur
des faits et pas sur des présomptions ou
sur la mauvaise humeur du moment où sur
l'émotion de monsieur darmanin scruter
celle qui pose des problèmes dans le
cadre de la loi telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui parce que ce que veulent ces
gens ces terroristes
c'est aussi nous analyse sur un terrain
qui n'est plus celui des lois de la
république les lois de la république qui
nous assure aujourd'hui de pouvoir vivre
ensemble donc c'est ça que je voudrais
rappeler et donc nous on est constant on
a été tout à fait cohérent et constant
nous étions à la marche en mémoire
amérique ne nous étions le 10 novembre
contre l'islamophobie et nous étions
encore ce dimanche massivement pour les
rassemblements pour la mémoire de samuel
papier vous voyez que nous sommes
cohérents constant et que les gens qui
cherchent à nous faire à nous livrer à
la vindicte pour sur des fausses des
fausses vérités en fait utilisent les
mêmes les mêmes méthodes que ce qu'il
prétend de bon dans des étangs du saut
c'est quand tout vous entendez les
prud'hommes dire bah voilà les les lois
suffisent aujourd'hui pour combattre le
terrorisme islamiste qu'est ce que vous
répondez non mais bien sûr je dirais que
pour le coup on a un arsenal juridique
assez suffisant c'est la seule chose
qu'ils vont que c'est une volonté
politique pour les mettre en oeuvre
et oui il est vrai aujourd'hui la loi
existe et pas besoin de nouvelles lois
pour expulser tous les fichiers s est
rangé pour radicalisation y a pas besoin
de nouvelles lois pour expulser les
imams qui prêchent la haine qui prêchent
la haine des juifs et la haine des
homosexuels la haine des femmes
à longueur de prêches il n'y a pas
besoin de nouvelle loi on peut le faire
mais encore faut-il vouloir le faire et
c'est tout le problème de du
gouvernement et du président de la
république
ensuite moi j'entends bien ce que disait
monsieur le député mais il ya un moment
donné je lisais une langue n'est pas
cohérent et vous êtes juste très embêté
avec les différentes positions que vous
avez prises tantôt par idéologie tantôt
par intérêt électoraliste mais vous êtes
très embêté ce qu'il n'y a aucune
cohérence à aller manifester avec le ccf
avec les islamistes
avec des personnes qui font hurler
allahou akbar à quelques mètres du
bataclan et de l'autre côté elle
ensuite à une allée à une manifestation
où cet islamisme à tuer le livre des
armes à monsieur kuna les réponses elles
ont crû dames on n'a pas entendu le
début de votre intervention
non mais je trouve assez extraordinaire
de prendre des leçons de cohérence de
monsieur du social il faudrait que quand
même rappeler que monsieur claude
hermant et un cadre du service d'ordre
du front national qu'il est celui qui a
fourni des hommes des armes à monsieur
coulibaly pour faire des massacres et
spacieux que c'est un a d'ailleurs un
adhérent dur dur du rassemblement
national qui a fait une filiale détenue
basque et une mosquée de bayonne donc
s'il vous plaît gardez un peu de mesure
soyez soyez plutôt à faire le ménage
devant devant vous et sur cette question
je voudrais me ne parlait pas en même
temps ne parle c'est fini c'est loïc
prud'hommes et vous répondrai ensuite
gaëtan du sausset oui je voulais
terminer sur aussi tous ces gens qui
nous qui nous montre du doigt pour
masquer leurs propres intérêts si je
pense au ministre de l'intérieur
précédent qui malgré tout l'arsenal
législatif qui existent n'ont rien fait
et aujourd'hui voudrait me faire porter
le chapeau de responsabilité je pense à
monsieur valls ou à monsieur cazeneuve
donc tout ça est vraiment assez odieux
et en plus relève vraiment de
contrevérités et nous on a été je vous
dis constant constant sur nos prises de
position nous on fait bien
la différence entre l'obscurantisme et
l'islamisme et toutes les dérives de des
religions et de la radicalisation dans
toutes les religions et nous y sommes
tout à fait attentifs et nous nous
pourrons nous prenons pour qu'il y ait
eu des moyens qu'ils soient vraiment mis
sur le renseignement parce qu'on voit
aussi que cette affaire là et il
semblerait d'après les éléments que nous
avons à cette heure et je voudrais clic
ou convient aussi le temps d'analyser
tout ça
il hisse en bref qu'il ya quand même un
défaut du renseignement intérieur à
pouvoir signaler à pouvoir tracer et à
pouvoir croiser les des fichiers et les
signalements entre l'éducation nationale
et le renseignement territoriale 300
nouveaux entre 3 200 livres aux
policiers pour leur enseignement annoncé
ce soir guettant du sausset vous vouliez
répondre à loïc prud'hommes
on vous eh oui bien sûr juste un petit
mot d'ailleurs pour le renseignement
c'est bien or en france et qu'on
continue à soutenir aussi bien
moralement juridiquement que
matériellement les les renseignements il
faut savoir qu'ils ont déjà un travail
excellentes si on veut les aider
maintenant il fait il suffit d'abord
devait être expulsé je le disais tous
les étrangers fichet ça permettra déjà
de soulager un certain nombre d'heures
qu'ils comment dire qu'ils lui mettent à
profit justement pour surveiller ces
personnes là qui te fait n'ont rien à
faire chez nous alors maintenant encore
une fois je suis désolé revient là
dessus mais je comprends qu'ils aient
toute une partie de la classe politique
y soit très gênée d'avoir participé à
des manifestations avec le ccis mais pas
seulement alors je oui il ya la france
un soubise d'ailleurs je crois qu'il ya
un certain nombre de personnes lors de
la manifestation république qui vont
réserver un accueil pas des plus
chaleureux parce qu'il ne supporte pas
justement la contradiction qui est la
vôtre je pense que ce sont aussi vos
anciens alliés du parti socialiste qui
au moment où vous étiez allé manifester
est pas loin du bataclan encore une fois
que les islamistes y ccf vous ont dit
que vous faisiez une erreur à ce moment
là ce n'est pas le rassemblement
national qui vous le dit ce sont vos
partenaires du parti socialiste mais
quand je vous disais vous n'êtes pas les
seuls
le parti socialiste lui même dès 2015
participer à un dîner de gala avec le
ccf mais moi ya d'autres choses qui
m'inquiètent indépendamment des prises
de positions des partis politiques qui
parfois peuvent évoluer en fonction des
tendances du moment c'est que si on
prend le cc hier ils sont intervenus par
exemple en 2016 dans 42 écoles avec
l'aval donc du ministère de l'éducation
nationale du moment avec l'aval des
académies scolaires et cetera qu'est ce
qui fait que qu'est ce qui explique un
moment donné dans ce pays on est une
administration juridiction qui laisse la
place à des islamistes dans nos écoles
et qui trois ans quatre ans après décide
de dissoudre l'association il ya une
incohérence qui est totale et j'espère
qu'un jour maintenant une enquête
là-dessus pour savoir qui allait cesser
islamistes s'exprimer haut et le gamin
dans nos écoles
alors en tout cas le ccf de son côté a
réagi regardez depuis hier nous sommes
la cible de menaces de mort et d'une
campagne de haine qui exigent la
dissolution du ccf devant autant de
calomnies d'une incroyable indécence
compte tenu du contexte notre équipe
reçoit un soutien ccf grandissant merci
du fond du coeur alors loïc prud'hommes
pour voulait s'essayer à ces le bouc
émissaire dans cette terrible affaire où
il a effectivement eu une réelle
responsabilité dans la mort du
professeur de l'enseignant je vous le
disais tout à l'heure il faut danser sur
ces sujets des terroristes ne garder du
sang froid et ne pas agir sous le coup
de l'émotion
donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui on a les
moyens de savoir si deux ccf respecte et
à respecter les lois de la république
c'est ces dernières années depuis depuis
sa création jusqu'à aujourd'hui et
l'arsenal est tout à fait suffisant et
donc moi je n'ai pas accès au dossier je
ne je n'ai pas les éléments et donc je
ne peux pas le dire si il est et c'est
pour ça que je disais qu'il fallait
absolument le respect de la loi et parce
que ce sera sans appel s'ils ont
enfreint la loi
il faut les interdire et point barre n'y
a aucune discussion à avoir là dessus et
ça je suis très clair par contre il faut
s'assurer que et bien des éléments
factuels tangibles qui soit conforme à
nos lois parce qu'on ne peut pas
appliquer les mêmes méthodes que ce que
l'on prétend compact combattre à savoir
la vindicte
et des choses qui sont approximatives
donc oui s'il y a des éléments il faut
il faut interdire le ccis et voilà on
saura et invite à garder aussi un peu de
sang-froid et à regarder le dossier sur
la durée je voulais revenir sur les
moyens aussi parce que cette affaire
passe et seief on le voit est assez lié
avec la sphère des réseaux sociaux et de
comment on a été quand même confronté à
cette vindicte sur les réseaux sociaux
il a été même prononcé le terme de
fatwas je pense qu'il ya aussi le
problème de des moyennes la surveillance
des réseaux sociaux le leur de la
cellule pharos qui s'occupe d'eux des
signalements sur les réseaux sociaux a
géré par an chaque année 280 milles
signalement et 28 agents 10000
signalement par agent ça fait plus de
cinquante par jour vous voyez bien qu'il
ya un petit souci à pouvoir surveiller
comment ces messages peuvent être
distillé les appels à rennes peuvent
être distillé sans que personne ne s'en
émeuve ne s'en rend compte
avant que l'inévitable l'horreur soit
soit commise et ça ça me paraît aussi un
élément important à prendre en compte
aujourd'hui il faut mettre ces moyens là
pour surveiller les réseaux sociaux je
vous rappelle que twitter ou facebook ne
sont ne sont pas des éditeurs ils sont
juste des hébergeurs et donc c'est alors
à puissance publique de faire respecter
la loi sur ces réseaux bien entendu
c'est auxerre pour conclure les réseaux
sociaux c'est eux qu'il faut montrer du
doigt finalement plus que le 6 eev et
toutes ces associations dans cette
affaire selon vous non mais s'il voulait
qu'on responsabilise les grands patrons
de facebook twitter etc
oui évidemment et
leurs règlements ou leurs intérêts ne
passe pas au dessus des lois de la
république puisque les lois sociales
décidées par le peuple donc le peuple
aurait que le peuple mais maintenant
encore une fois il faut pas il faut il
faut passer preuve de retenue face aux
dangers de l'islamisme dans notre pays
l'état de droit évidemment encore une
fois nous je me sais ce que je disais
précédemment les lois existent il faut
les appliquer mais il faut arrêter de
tergiverser de d'hésiter de ne pas
vouloir y aller parce que ça fait
maintenant beaucoup trop longtemps qu'il
y à des attentats dans notre pays il ya
un problème avec l'islamisme radical
si on prendre ne serait-ce que dans un
seul lieu de l'école y avait eu le
problème du foulard de creil on a eu
ensuite suite aux attentats de 2001 des
enseignants qui déjà à l'époque d'alerté
qui avait des élèves qui criaient vive
et de laden dans les couloirs rien n'a
été fait et on a qui ont sorti des
bouquins ils ont été complètement
blacklisté par leurs collègues
enseignants et surtout par la hiérarchie
scolaire
on se souvient des minutes de silence
lors des attentats de mohamed merah dans
certaines avaient été perturbés dans un
certain nombre d'écoles et également le
mouvement pas de vagues
et là encore dernièrement on a des
témoignages qui commencent à sortir un
peu plus parce que les langues se
délient avec notamment un professeur qui
disait que il avait étudié en cours il
avait montré des vidéos de pakistanais
qui brûlaient des drapeaux français
suite à la publication des caricatures
de mahomet par charlie hebdo et des
élèves se levait et applaudissait
alors quand est-ce qu'on va arrêter de
se cacher les yeux et qu'on va
véritablement agir contre ça donc
arrêtons d'hésiter arrêtons de
tergiverser
trente six mille fois il ya énormément
de choses à faire à commencer par
évidemment la dissolution qui s'essayait
merci à tous les deux d'avoir accepté
notre invitation sur notre antenne merci
à vous gaëtan du soc est membre du
conseil national du rassemblement
national
merci à vous loïc prud'hommes député la
france insoumise de la 3e
circonscription de gironde à la
situation sanitaire en france à présent
et un point sur les derniers chiffres
santé publique france dénombre treize
mille deux cent quarante trois nouvelles
contaminations kovy dans 24 heures
cent quarante six personnes sont
décédées à l'hôpital le taux de
positivité des tests s'établit désormais
à 13 4 % au total le nombre de morts
s'élève lui à 33 milles à 623 personnes
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
mélina dufrègne la fléche l infirmière
libérale membre du collectif sos
soignants en danger mélina dufresne la
fléchette merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france alors pour commencer comment est
ce que vous vivez en tant qu'infirmière
libéral ces dernières semaines avec le
co vide
bonsoir
comment je les vis avec avec une
certaine angoisse parce qu'on a on
perçoive une secte seconde vague est ici
est présente dans les
pyrénées-orientales et qu'elle monte
petit à petit c'est pas un tsunami comme
comme étaient présentés là et se
présentait la première vague là la
seconde vague
elle monte elle monte voilà voilà
comment comment j'aperçois c'est ce que
vous constatez dans vos tournées
quotidiennes
c'est ce qu'on sait ce qu on sait ce
qu'on entend c'est ce qu'on entend on
l'a on n'a pas encore de soins à nos
domiciles à au domicile on l'entend
surtout au niveau hospitalier et pas par
encore ans libérable
alors dans ce dont je suis certain alors
justement en tant qu'infirmière libéral
dans votre activité quotidienne quels
sont les changements par rapport à la
première vague est ce que vous faites
des tests qu'ovide par exemple qu'est-ce
qui a évolué ce qui a évolué et c'est le
effectivement je me retrouve à faire
plus de prises de sang de gens qui ont
déjà été éventuellement testés positifs
et qui m'appelle parce que ils se
sentent pas bien et qu'ils ont fait par
exemple appelle la toute dernière
c'était un entre guillemets c'était un
pompier volontaire qui qui a été
contaminée par le cos vide et qui
sentait pas bien et qui appeler sos
médecins et sos médecins les prescrit
une un bilan sanguin faire en urgence
donc voilà le type de soins les tests
pcr sont faites en laboratoire dans
village dans lequel j'exerce et
concernant le concernant votre matériel
de protection
on se souvient en pleine crise sanitaire
lors de la première vague il en manquait
beaucoup celle libéré hier les
infirmières libérales également
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous en avez
assez oui parce que enfin oui parce que
bon honnêtement je m'en sers pas
spécialement puisque j'ai quand même
j'ai pas de patients qui sont atteints
du duc o gide
par contre j'ai gardé ce matériel qui
n'a pas été fourni par l'état parce que
l'état nous a parlé que des masques et
nous a fourni que ce type de matériel or
que pour intervenir auprès de jean cau
vide il ya tout un matériel qui est qui
et qui
dont on a besoin on ne sait pas dire de
blues de surbourg aux devises hier de
masques de chaussures chaussures tout ça
ça n'a pas été du tout du tout fourni
par les torts l'état nous a fourni que
des masques au départ oui ça a été très
difficile d'en trouver en nous en a
offert donc ce matériel j'en ai pris
soin je les gardais je le garde pour
faire face éventuellement à
ces deux secondes balles alors ces
derniers jours on a beaucoup parlé des
accords du ségur de la santé sur votre
statut il a eu aucune influence
aucune incidence aucune incidence non
non absolument pour vous donc absolument
pas absolument pas il faut savoir que
les infirmiers libéraux une cote actions
de leurs actes qui existe depuis 1972
avec des actes qui n'existe toujours pas
c'est pas dire par exemple la prise de
la tension artérielle chez un patient
n'existe pas il n'y a aucune
nomenclature pour beaucoup d'actes ça
c'est l'acte le plus on rencontre le
plus il n'y a pas de cotation par contre
leur l'état s'est empressé de nous
prendre entre guillemets une cotation
par rapport à de la télétransmission
c'est à dire des suivi de patients
atteints du coc vide derrière des écrans
ça par contre établi s'est empressé de
pondre une une cotation par contre pour
des actes qui existe depuis depuis tout
le temps
nous n'avons toujours pas de cotation
beaucoup d'infirmières de l'hôpital
public aujourd'hui jette l éponge
qu'est ce qu'il en est les infirmières
libérales est ce qu'il y a un certain
ras-le-bol une envie de changer de
métier oui tout à fait
oui il ya un ras-le-bol parce qu'il ya
toujours non ça on n'a aucune
considération notre métier que ça soit
l'état qui entre guillemets nous a pondu
un celi bur sans demander quoi que ce
soit sans demander quoi que ce soit quoi
et d'ailleurs on apparaît pas enfin on
est on est les oubliés de ce c'est dur
tout simplement en quoi effectivement
les gens ont envie de changer de métier
pour l'instant moi c'est pas mon cas
j'adore mon métier je suis et je suis
heureuse de faire le métier que j'exerce
par contre oui il ya de quoi être être
dégoûté être dégoûté déjà par le fait
qu'à l'heure actuelle notre notre
diplôme est toujours reconnu base +2 or
que nous avons quand même bac + 3 mai +3
et demi
déjà c'est quand même un manque de
considération de notre profession un
manque de considération aussi par le
fait qu'on nous demande jamais notre
avis nous les libéraux notre ordre
infirmier est absent absent de tous de
toute façon il en dessous tout notre
ordre
oui il ya de quoi jeter l'épongé tout à
fait le manque de considération avec des
gens qu'on soigne moi j'ai trouvé que
notre ma profession s'est dégradée ça
fait 15 ans que je veux qu'il revienne
libéral
je trouve que même auprès des gens que
je soigne pas pour certains c'est un le
soin est devenu il devenu un service en
voilà y'a plus il ya plus cette relation
qu'avait requis avaient avant moi je
trouve que il ya effectivement de quoi
jeter l'épongé
merci beaucoup mais lena dufrègne la
fléchette d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
infirmières libérales et membre du
collectif sos soignants en danger dans
quelques instants nous parlerons du haut
karabagh le cessez le feu entré en
vigueur samedi soir à minuit 1 aura à
nouveau tenu que quelques heures
et bakou et erevan sa cuisse déjà
mutuellement d'avoir violé et puis
direction les états unis à deux semaines
de la présidentielle les deux candidats
enchaînent les meetings avant l'ultime
débat ce jeudi
restez avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
à l'époque il y avait une concurrence
qui était assez violente d'ailleurs
entre les russes et les américains alors
que j'étais destinée à voler avec les
russes mais une opportunité s'est
ouverte de faire partie du deuxième
groupe d'astronautes européens qui m'a
envoyé aussitôt à la nasa
et là j'ai une chance extraordinaire de
la nasa m'a entraîné qualifié affecté en
vol comme un des leurs on est loin de la
guerre des étoiles à en est quand même
dans une espèce de con fraternité et de
solidarité l'exploration au sens large
est une activité en coopération
internationale où on se rend service
entre nations qui pourtant au même
moment son sujet d'embargo et de
conflits géopolitiques savoir est ce que
l'homme peut vivre et travailler dans
l'espace est ce qu'il existe de la vie
ailleurs
est ce qu'on pourra un jour s'installer
durablement sur d'autres corps célestes
tout ça on le fait en coopération
internationale malgré des tensions
à la surface de nos terres
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
petits éco politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité
les ide et courageuse des mots qui
comptent
la peine en soir vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui une gauche qui extrait dans
un musée tous les témoins de notre
époque sont dans la grande interview un
des sujets les plus préoccupants du
moment et celui de l'otan et de la
défense en europe et tout au long des
années l'alliance atlantique s'est
investi dans des guerres qui n'étaient
pas toujours réellement en ligne avec
ses objectifs statutaires
la situation s'est aggravée avec le
début d' attaques contre la frégate
courbet 10 juillet les mots n'assure
contre la grèce et la présence de dieu à
dist syriens venus d'idlib haut karabakh
incapable de régler ses conflits
internes le temps est devenu un frein
politique à l'unité européenne
c'est à l'europe d'être en capacité
d'assumer la responsabilité de sa propre
sécurité et d'agir de manière autonome
quand c'est nécessaire
mais compte tenu des divergences avec l
europe pourront nous le faire
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir et bienvenue sur rt france si
vous nous rejoignez il est 21h30 heure
française
une rencontre a eu lieu ce matin à
moscou entre le chef de la diplomatie
russe sergueï lavrov et la secrétaire
général du conseil de l'europe le
ministre russe des affaires étrangères a
évoqué la question du haut karabagh les
précisions de notre correspondant à
moscou juan peron le ministre russe des
affaires étrangères tout comme son hôte
du jour
ce sont tous les deux félicités de la
réintégration des parlementaires russes
au sein du conseil de l'europe
après cinq années d'absence à ce titre
sergueï lavrov a rappelé tout l'intérêt
que la russie porte pour les travaux de
cette institution européenne en
particulier en matière de sécurité de
stabilité sur le vieux continent
mais quand les journalistes ont pu poser
leurs questions on en est rapidement
arrivé à la situation dans le haut
karabagh et en particulier la question
du non respect du cessez-le-feu
je pense qu'aujourd'hui le plus
important et je pense pas que cela
demande un gros effort c'est d'arrêter
toute forme de confrontation temps entre
les parties que le niveau des
responsables des acteurs responsables au
niveau international je pense pas que sa
demande de grands efforts ici il faut un
système de contrôle de respect du
cessez-le-feu nous travaillons
activement notamment avec le ministère
de la défense et avec nos collègues
d'azerbaïdjan et d'arménie et nous
espérons que très prochainement un
mécanisme de contrôle sera validée alors
quel que soit le sujet des discussions
comme aujourd'hui l'europe et plus
particulièrement les relations entre la
russie et le conseil de l'europe la
situation dans le haut-karabakh s'est
une nouvelle fois retrouvés au coeur des
préoccupations et non sans raison une
trêve extrêmement précaires donc dans
cette région de la transcaucasie presque
immédiatement après son entrée en
vigueur
erevan et bakou se sont accusés
mutuellement d'avoir repris les combats
l'armée
annonce qu'elle va reconnaître
l'indépendance du haut karabagh si
l'azerbaïdjan ne s'engage pas dans la
voie des négociations l'onu de son côté
condamne les attaques sur les
populations civiles et à ce sujet
écoutez comment réagissent les premiers
concernés par ces affrontements il y à
un cessez le feu mais l'armé ni ne le
respecte pas il y en a d'autres comme
vous le voyez ils ont détruit cet
endroit mais nous n'irons nulle part
mais l'arménie ne se contente pas
d'utiliser son pouvoir pour bombarder
nos soldats il débarque également les
citoyens ici en réalité la trêve n'a pas
été respectée en ce qui concerne nos
positions défensives
il n'y a pas eu de tirs mais nous
entendons des explosions sur nos
positions de droite et de gauche
je vous assure que c'est de la part des
adversaires et non de nous il s'agit
d'une tentative de sabotage de la part
des amériques quand les attaquants ça de
plus de trois semaines donc que les
combats s'intensifient dans cette région
contestée les cessez le feu
elle n'y font rien ou presque à tel
point qu'on craint qu'une guerre
s'installe sur le long terme
retour en images sur la chronologie des
événements
[Musique]
on
oh
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
françois costantini docteur en sciences
politiques spécialisés de relations
internationales
françois costantini merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors
trois semaines maintenant que les
combats ont commencé une trêve sans
effet qu'est-ce qui pourrait dénouer la
situation d'une façon ou d'une autre
aujourd'hui bien ce conflit entre
l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan sur le
karabakh est différent des précédents
parce que cette fois ci à l'origine du
conflit et et expliquant également sa
densité plus aiguë que qu'auparavant
c'est l'implication directe de la
turquie erdogan on sait les stratégies
belliciste tous azimuts sur plusieurs
fronts en méditerranée orientale en
syrie en libye
et là il ya littéralement poussé
l'azerbaïdjan à l'affrontement et on
sait qu'aujourd'hui que pour m en mai
c'est en mettant la turquie à la raison
qu'on arrêtera le conflit puisque le
conflit n'est pas seulement une affaire
de cessez-le-feu entre l'arménie et
l'azerbaïdjan
c'est que l'azerbaïdjan était
littéralement mis sous tutelle par la
turquie il ya eu des manoeuvres à partir
en important de l'anac una catch
alliance et 7
cette région azé riquet situe sur le
flanc méridional de 2,2 de l'arménie est
que cette fois ci en effet on est on est
plus seulement dans on voit notamment
que les négociations à moscou patine
parce que en effet les azéris sont
littéralement placé sous sous le
commandement et du fait de l'armement d
instruction militaire est également des
des milliers de djihadistes syriens qui
ont été envoyés sur le sur le front par
par la turquie sont donc sous la soul à
coude d'ankara et c'est là dessus que
achopper les négociations
justement il avait fallu plusieurs jours
en guise aux diplomates du groupe de
minsk pour obtenir que l'azerbaïdjan et
l'arménie accepte d'endosser le texte a
basé sur les accords de moscou du samedi
précédent
un texte qui est elle-même pour les deux
parties alors que propose est maintenant
bien proposer tout simple c'est que il
va falloir condamné notamment les
agressions de de la turquie le fait que
la poule la turquie a poussé poussé à
l'affrontement est en effet la russie et
plus gêné parce que la russie 1
plutôt médiateur on dit qu'elle penche
du côté de l'arménie s'est pas tout à
fait exact elle a toujours eu un rôle
médiateur elle a fourni d'ailleurs elle
fournit d'ailleurs plus d'armes en
proportion à l'azerbaïdjan et l'arménie
par les contrats traditionnels mais là
il est certain que la question se pose
avec l'implication directe de la turquie
c'est là-dessus qu'il faut poser faire
pression notamment sur la turquie et
faire en sorte que l impose ou du moins
qu'elle stoppe en quoi l'offensive azéri
mais ils ne sont pas que ce soit
actuellement dans ses plans c'est avant
dans ce contexte du coup qu'est ce qu'on
peut attendre de moscou selon vous
quelles interventions avec quels leviers
béa c'est le problème je pense qu'en
effet cette alliance contre nature entre
la turquie et la russie trouve
aujourd'hui en quelque sorte c'est tout
toutes ses limites
en effet il ya eu également une la
stratégie européenne qui a quelque peu
poussé la russie dans dans les bras la
turquie son petit c'est une alliance qui
allons voir moyen terme contre nature
mais en effet falloir que je pense qu'il
faut que la russie choisissent davantage
et qu'elle en est là en effet un
avantage elle a en effet un outil en
main qui est sa relation avec avec
ankara et qu'elle s'adresse directement
en quarts a justement pour mettre fin
aux hostilités je pense que c'est c'est
laid c'est là dessus qu'il faudra un
système puisque l'azerbaïdjan
aujourd'hui a été relancée je quitte à
le redire encore une fois à a relancé le
conflit justement par la seule influence
de la turquie donc c'est une médiation
plutôt russo turcs eux qui s'impose qui
sera à mon avis beaucoup plus fortes et
qui aura plus de porter qu'une sa
médiation à 0
arménienne et la turquie elle restera
fidèle à l'azerbaïdjan
oui bien sûr vous savez qu'ils les
airbags j'en avais eu toujours une
politique d'autonomie au plan politique
au plan économique elle avait essayé de
bâtir et que présent à liège sa propre
puissance à une politique notamment
d'investissements dans lés dans les pays
que c'est en tout cas ce grâce au gaz
dans un certain nombre de ceux de
société mais là il a il apparaît comme
que l'azerbaïdjan père est en quelque
sorte le pré carré qu'il avait mis peut
être 10 15 ans a dessiné et qu'il est
retombé en quelque sorte dans dans la
logique dans ta tentaculaire d'erdogan
ce qui est à mon sens une erreur de la
part des dirigeants azéri parce que il
avait une chance d'avoir une originalité
diplomatique un quant-à-soi politiques
et stratégiques
et ils sont en train de le perdre et je
pense à leurs dépends parce que je pense
que l'azerbaïdjan n'a pas à gagner dans
deux dans cette guerre c'est à dire que
même s'il ya des reconquêtes m pour être
que partielle et ne peuvent pas gagner
de façon absolue absolue fait face à
l'arménie donc je pense que en effet
l'azerbaïdjan c'est en quelque sorte à
insérer dans la logique actuelle n'est
ottomane de d'erdogan et puis seulement
dans une pâture 6 avec l'azerbaïdjan
mais on également dans une logique les
hôtes néo ottomane qui va loin et je
pense que c'est là dessus sur cette
relation avec la turquie que
l'azerbaïdjan a pris un certain nombre
de risques d'appui aux cibles et de
risques est ce que paris et washington
peuvent faire ont les moyens de faire
pression sur la turquie dans ce dossier
ils ont que d'amener diplomatique un
paris washington et moscou il faut
rappeler comme vous l'avez du co préside
le groupe de contact de deux minsk qui a
été mis en place si ma mémoire est bonne
en 1994 à la suite du du conflit de 1992
mais
le bleu groupe n'a fait qu'activer en
quelque sorte les canaux diplomatiques
et en effet c'est une pression beaucoup
plus forte sur sur la turquie de la part
notamment de paris de washington des
pays européens est de moscou qui devrait
s'exercer pour que cessent ces
hostilités puisque des clés de l'est des
activités ne sont pas à erevan à bas
coûts mais plutôt en quarts donc c'est
là plutôt que doit se se concentrer les
discussions et les pressions
diplomatiques
alors en attendant de futures
discussions ou de pressions s qui en
attendant on doit craindre un véritable
bain de sang pour les populations
civiles
oui c'est à craindre c'est le genre de
conflit vous avez c'est un peu compliqué
par clairement meurtrier depuis
pratiquement une trentaine d'années
puisqu'on parle de 92 mais le confie à
même préexisté à la chute de l'urss
c'est en 1988 que sont apparues les
premières tensions sur le nagorny
karabakh
donc on en effet c'est une logique
d'affrontement deux peuples qui sont
fondamentalement hostile qui sont
irréductibles l'un à l'autre de deux
cultures différents un peuple en plus
ils peuvent par millien qui directement
a souffert nage une aussi
particulièrement atroces perpétrés par
les turcs
il ya un siècle donc qui est une
question défense je vous rappellerai
toujours ce ce fameux mot de sakharov
qui disait le nagorny karabakh pour
l'arménie c'est une question de vie et
de mort merci beaucoup françois
costantini nous avoir éclairé je
rappelle que vous êtes docteur en
sciences politiques et spécialiste des
relations internationales et on poursuit
avec la campagne présidentielle
américaine c'est dans deux semaines le
vote sera le 3 novembre et les deux
candidats multiplient les invectives ce
dimanche donald trump était dans le
nevada tandis que son adversaire
démocrate joe biden cette étape en
caroline du nord des états et qui
pourrait faire basculer le scrutin à
françois xavier lambert
un petit pas de danse pour montrer sa
forme retrouvée dans le nevada donald
trump poursuit sa série frénétique de
meetings face à des partisans galvanisés
le président américain en a profité pour
vanter de nouveau sa guérison rapide du
coronavirus à la traîne dans les
sondages
il a aussi appelé à l'unité des
républicains après certaines critiques à
son encontre
donald trump a surtout repris ses
attaques virulentes contre son rival joe
biden si vous votez pour baden il vendra
vos emplois à la chine
il abandonnera votre futur aux mains du
virus il va mettre en place un
confinement
il écoutera les scientifiques moi si
j'avais écouté les scientifiques nous
aurions en ce moment même un pays en
pleine récession
au lieu d'être une fusée regardez
simplement les chiffre à près de 40 km
de là joe biden a choisi la caroline du
nord pour cimenter sa campagne dans une
ambiance beaucoup plus calme le
démocrate a dénoncé la gestion de la
pandémie par la maison blanche
il a également lancé un appel à
l'électorat afro américain en rendant
hommage à georges floyd tué par un
policier blanc fin mai à minneapolis
pensez à ce que ça suppose d'aimer ce
pays aujourd'hui en étant une personne
noire
c'est un amour profond pour ce pays
pendant trop longtemps il n'a pas été
reconnue nous avons besoin d'un
dirigeant qui fasse baisser les tensions
qui rétablisse les lignes de
communication et qui nous rassemblent
pour guérir et espérer en tant que
président c'est exactement ce que je
ferai le discours de joe biden semble
pour l'instant faire mouche
il mène de 9 points dans les sondages by
dane et surtout en avance dans les états
indécis qui peuvent faire basculer
l'élection
les deux candidats se retrouveront jeudi
prochain asheville pour leur dernier
débat présidentiel
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis houston avec joe dougherty
soutien de donald trump c'est notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur
[Musique]
joberty merci d'être en direct avec nous
sur rt france alors bien qu'ils soient
en retard de près de 1 9 point
le président américain a team toujours
une chance de gagner à l'élection
américaine et du théâtre des lumières en
les sondages ont prouvé qu'ils arrêtent
une page dans les gammes et contrainte à
remporter la victoire pour plus de 300
grands électeurs et c'est le theule très
tard dans la soirée de la journée
d'élection qu'on a réalisé que hillary
clinton n'est pas qu'un lieu
effectivement il encore de bonnes
chances car l'histoire l'a montré les
sondages on tarde alors donald trump
tente de conserver plusieurs est un
majeur dans la course à la
présidentielle
la floride l'ohio la géorgie ainsi que
l'agoa est ce qu'il peut y parvenir et
comment vous en avez évoqué trois autres
mais au total d'un mineur il passe
beaucoup de temps dans son état il aussi
en tout le pays
si l on regarde les meetings de
l'entrepôt des milliers de personnes se
rendent sur place avec enthousiasme
attendent parfois quatre cinq voire 15
heures à faire la queue s'agissant des
meetings de joe dalton on voit quelques
chansons de personnes et il est très
difficile de savoir ce qui se passe je
pense donc que donald trump a bien plus
dès lors les peuples derrière lui et il
nous fera ce qu'il faut pour remporter
ces états clés alors on note par
ailleurs une très forte participation
avec elle les votes par correspondance à
qui cela profite il
il faut regarder les zetas
tegick car en cette période ce qui est
important soixante deux millions de
personnes sont enregistrés sur les
listes électorales de ces neuf et à
environ 9 millions de votes ont été
enregistrés et ont dit que la plupart
des fêtes déjà enregistré tête en faveur
des démocrates
les nombreux et des votes des votes
anticipés les sondages cela ne fait pas
de grande différence
ce qui est important c'est ce qu'il va
se passer il y a dans quinze jours le 2
novembre lorsque les gens vont réagir
donald trump
alors pour le dernier débat prévue le 22
octobre
à quoi est ce qu'on peut s'attendre
entre les deux candidats une question
que côté de l'équipe de notre enfant je
pense qu'on évoquera les succès de 20 à
30 le taux de chômage le plus bas de
l'histoire
les plus importantes baisses d'impôts la
paix au moyen orient
voilà le programme de donald trump
voici les succès de donald trump ce sont
des faits quant à ce que joe barton va
évoquer il pourrait évoquer le manque de
réactivité face à la période où pourrait
en faire un sujet majeur il pourrait
parler du changement climatique
ce sont les sujets de leurs tracts
habituels comme par exemple les
divisions raciales
ce sont des choses qu'il ment sur le
tapis parce que aucun autre sujet a
évoqué a passé de très longues années au
gouvernement et lui a rien à montrer
pour cela il ne peut pas mettre en avant
des succès même si on lui demande
régulièrement carrément pas à son
tableau
donald trump est président depuis moins
de quatre ans et il a déjà beaucoup de
succès dont il va parler bien sûr
alors on entend des voix dans le camp
républicain qui s'élèvent contre donald
trump est ce que cela peut lui porter
préjudice
je ne suis pas il faut regarder qui
s'exprime la semaine un mot enfin un
sénateur du nebraska républicain s'est
fait attrapé lors d'un coup de téléphone
avec ses électeurs
il est est toujours là et d'autres
personnes ni ce qu'on appelle des vidéos
des républicains en ont seulement
essayent de plaire à leurs électeurs
il veut les garder leur siège ils
veulent rester au poste ce genre de
personne ne fait qu'essayer de courtiser
les personnes des deux côtés dans les
deux parties mais je ne pense pas que
cela va me mener à de bons résultats
pour ces personnes alors il ya aussi ces
rumeurs qui font état de certains
membres du parti républicain qui se
mettraient une victoire de joe biden à
la présidentielle tout en gardant la
majorité républicaine au sénat est ce
que cela vous semble plausible
la majorité républicaine au sénat est
très forte et l'une des fonctions les
plus importantes du sénat c'est de nous
mais edelia real joue les juges de la
cour suprême par exemple c'était un
sujet très importante en ce moment je
pense que les républicains ils vont
garder le sénat personnes qui je reste
fidèle à la politique de donald trump
ont beaucoup plus de chances de
remporter leur siège que les autres donc
oui je pense que la majorité va rester
conservatrice au sénat et je pense même
que les conservateurs on veut remporter
la chambre des représentants
donc nous aurons ces trois institutions
si donald trump remporté les élections
et cela voudrait dire beaucoup de bien
pour le peuple américain
merci à vous aux jo dougherty je
rappelle que vous êtes un soutien de
donald trump et c'est la fin de cette
émission mais restez avec nous on se
retrouve dans quelques minutes à 22
heures heure de paris pour un point
complet sur l'actualité a tout de suite
sur rt france
[Musique]
il
la france fait partie de ces pays qui
ont mal géré cette crise je crois qu'on
ne pouvait pas échapper au confinement à
partir du moment où on n'avait pas su
anticiper cette crise et et la préparer
il ya un point d'interrogation pour
l'opinion c'est qu'on a beaucoup
emprunté je crois qu'on pouvait pas
faire autrement
l'échec sanitaire entraîne l'échec
économique
c'est sans doute la dernière fois que la
france peut emprunter 20 à 30% de son
pub pour essayer